a
[Música]
ah
en los últimos meses en colombia resuena
el grito nos están matando llega a
distintos grupos sociales pero sobre
todo lo hace con los pueblos indígenas
lo demuestran los datos de la ong
indepaz desde la firma de paz de 2016
entre el gobierno y la guerrilla de las
farc al menos 300 líderes indígenas han
sido asesinados unos ataques que se han
recrudecido en 2020 según la asociación
de cabildos indígenas del norte del
cauca al menos 76 indígenas del
departamento del cauca han sido
asesinados en 2020 en una
reconfiguración del conflicto que diluye
las esperanzas de paz sonado fue también
el atentado hace apenas dos semanas
contra una de las grandes figuras
indígenas colombianas
el senador feliciano valencia o
denuncias como las de los 2.100
indígenas confinados por choques entre
grupos armados a finales del mes de
octubre esto en un país en el que los
indígenas representan un 5 por ciento de
la población de 50 millones de
habitantes con 115 pueblos indígenas de
los cuales 68 están en vías de extinción
y con una pobreza del 63 por ciento el
triple que el promedio nacional
la violencia contra los indígenas en
brasil aumentó el año pasado un 150 por
ciento según un reciente informe que
muestra que hubo 256 denuncias por actos
criminosos básicamente invasión de
reservas indígenas y también explotación
ilegal de recursos eso sí los asesinatos
bajaron levemente pero siguen siendo muy
altos hubo 113 casos este el año pasado
este año también ha habido en plena
pandemia varios casos en junio dos
indígenas de la etnia yanomami fueron
matados a tiros por buscadores de oro la
novedad es que en esta circunstancia
suele reinar la impunidad pero a finales
de octubre la policía federal emitió
cuatro órdenes de busca y captura contra
los involucrados de esos asesinatos hay
que recordar que la reserva de yanomami
que se encuentra en el norte de brasil
en el estado de roraima cuenta con más
de 20 mil buscadores de oro ilegales
[Música]
en los meses recientes se ha recrudecido
un añejo conflicto agrario en la zona
indígena de los altos de chiapas al
sureste de méxico
los comuneros del municipio de aldama
acusan la presencia y operación de
grupos paramilitares en el vecino
municipio de chenalhó el motivo de la
disputa es la posesión de 60 hectáreas
de tierras de cultivo y el saldo a las
fechas de una treintena de muertos una
cantidad similar de heridos y miles de
desplazados sobre todo del municipio de
aldama que han tenido que dejar sus
hogares ante las constantes agresiones
armadas el gobierno federal ha intentado
mediar en el conflicto proponiendo la
división de las hectáreas sin embargo
los comuneros de chenalhó exigen el pago
de 2.5 millones de dólares y una
indemnización por cada uno de sus
muertos y heridos hay voces que
interpretan este conflicto como las
secuelas de la matanza de acteal en
diciembre de 1997 hay en chenalhó y por
la cual el gobierno de lópez obrador ha
ofrecido disculpas públicas de parte del
estado mexicano
[Música]